well good to see you again um sorry you
got two old guys again
this in this section we're going to talk
about
fitting non-linear functions and
non-linear models up to now we focus on
linear models
and what you'll see is that it's it's
actually very easy
to bring in non-linearity into your
model in somewhat seamless way
um and you'll see the tools are almost
as easy as they were when we're fitting
linear models
and we'll talk about a hierarchy of
methods some
completely straightforward and and some
slightly more sophisticated
and some of the actual you see today is
for trevor and i somewhat historical uh
the very first paper we ever wrote
together was called generalized additive
models uh he actually here
as graduate students here at stanford
and in the last part of the section
we'll talk about generalization models
which are a way of using
the tools for not for non-linearity for
more than one predictor oh yeah and
you know rob it just occurred to me that
that paper we wrote 30 years ago
still it's still good it's all good
okay okay
so
here we go
well
the first fact is
the truth is never linear
um that's a shocking thing for a
statistics professor to say
maybe i should qualify or almost never
well that is the truth linearity is an
approximation
and and often linearity assumption is
good enough and and that's why we we
like the linear model the approximation
is good enough and it gives us a nice
simple summary
but we need to go beyond linearity often
and we have lots of tools to do that
and in this section we're going to talk
about some of those
so there's the list polynomial step
function splines
local regression and generalized
additive models kind of increasing in in
complexity as we go down the list
and as you'll see they're just as easy
to work with as as linear models
so polynomial regression
we've really covered before and
we're going to when we introduce these
nonlinear methods we're going to
introduce them for the most part except
when we get to generalized additive
models with a single variable but you
know you'll see it's it's just as easy
to do it in many variables as well
and so
here's a polynomial
regression model
we've got
not only a linear term
but we've got polynomial terms as well
so there's x squared x cubed and so on
and we can go up to whatever degree we
like
and for the linear model um it's linear
the coefficient it's linear in the
coefficients but it's a non-linear
function of x
and in the left panel we see on the wage
data
a polynomial function fitted as a to age
that's a third degree i believe
polynomial
and you see the the fitted function and
you see pointwise standard error bands
that's these dotted bands here that's
one plus and minus one standard error
and it's a nonlinear function it seems
to capture what's going on in the data
i noticed the standard air bands are
wider at the ends there trevor is it
why is that
um that's a good point rob and that's
that's a result of the it's called
leverage the points right at the end you
notice the data thins out at the end so
there's not so much data there and and
so the information for fitting the curve
at the end is much less so the standard
error gets wider
but also points at the end we call it
wag in the tail of the dog right a
polynomial is a very flexible function
and it can especially flexible at the
end and those tails tend to wag around
and that standard area indicates it
in fact
in this in this figure on the right here
we fit in a using a polynomial to fit a
logistic regression
and to do that in this section we just
turn wage into a binary variable by
looking at whether wage is bigger than
250
k or not
and
and so that's a logistic regression out
trying to model the probability of that
event
and notice how wide the standard errors
are at the end right now well when i
first saw that i thought it was crazy
but then i realized this the vertical
scale is pretty stretched right so it's
only ranging up to point two
oh good point good point if you saw that
from zero to one it would look a lot
more narrow that's that's a very good
point and that's something to always
bear in mind you know the plot in scales
you know it's important what how you
decide on what scales to use and in this
case
as rob said it's only going up to 0.2
what you also notice here is
we've got this so-called rag plot
we see at the bottom of the plot where
all the zeros occurred that's these
little
spikes here it's kind of uniformly
across the range
and then above we've got where all the
ones occur and you'll notice there's
only there's one sort of in the middle
of the range and not many ones at the
end so there's really not any data at
all to estimate this function right at
the end
so in detail with polynomial regression
what you do is you create new variables
and in this case they're just
transformations of the original variable
so x
we make x1 is the original x x2 is x
squared and so on and then just treat
the problem as a multiple linear
regression model with these new derived
variables
um and in this case we're not really
interested in the coefficients we're
more interested in the fitted functions
at any particular value x zero
right we're interested in the composed
function
so once we fit the model we might say
well what does the function look like at
a new value x0 and you know and so the
coefficients itself aren't that
interesting
and and since the fitted function is is
actually a linear function of the
coefficients the beta ls l hats
okay we can get a simple expression for
the pointwise variances
so you say what is the variance of the
fitted function at x0
well
that fitted function at x0 is just a
linear function a linear combination of
the parameters
and and so
by using the the covariance matrix of
the fitted parameters you can then get
an expression a simple expression for
the variance of this fitted value we
describe this in more detail in the book
in somewhat more detail
and
it seems like we in the plot we actually
plot the fitted function plus or minus
two standard errors i said one earlier
and so getting these pointwise standard
errors is is fairly straightforward
a pointwise means that the standard
error
the standard error band is point wise
so the band is showing at any given
point what the standard error is this is
not to be confused with global
confidence bands which is another story
the other thing is how what degree do we
use
so here we were actually using a fourth
degree polynomial i said third but we
use fourth
so that d is obviously a parameter and
often we just pick d to be some small
number like two or three four in this
case or otherwise we can actually select
d by cross validation think of it as a
tuning parameter
for logistic regression it's it's the
details
are pretty much the same
in the as i said in the figure we this
is what we were modeling
um and so there's our inverse logistic
function and it's just a polynomial
instead of a linear function
and
one small detail it's somewhat important
is to get confidence intervals
what you do is if you try and get
confidence intervals for the
probabilities
using sort of direct methods you might
get outside the range 0 and 1. so what
you do is you get confidence intervals
for the fitted logit and then you put
them the upper and lower confidence band
endpoints through the inverse logic
transformation and those give you
the
the confidence intervals or the
in this case on for the for the fitted
probabilities
so that's a useful trick to bear in mind
okay
a few other points
with polynomial so we've just talked
about with a single variable for several
variables you can do it separately on
each variable
right so you just generate these
transformations on each variable and
then just stack them together in one big
matrix and and and fit a big linear
model in all these new derived variables
so if you've got if you've got a
variable x you might make x1 x2 up to
say x4 if you have another variable z
you can make z1 up to z4
then you just stack them all together
and make a big
model matrix and fit your linear model
and then you have to unpack the pieces
to compose the functions
and we'll see later on that the gam
technology generalized additive model
technology helps you do this in a
seamless way
there's some caveats with polynomial
regression
polynomials as i mentioned before have
notorious tail behavior very bad for
extrapolation those tails tend to wiggle
around and you really wouldn't want to
trust predictions beyond the range of
the data or even to near the end ends of
the data
and finally fitting a polynomial in r is
very simple here's
a simple expression for fitting a
polynomial in x to y
this is the model formula that you'd use
there's a poly function that generates
these these transformations for you and
it's as simple as that
and we'll see in the in the lab
we'll get some experience with that
step functions that's another way of
fitting non-linearities especially
popular in epidemiology and
biostatistics in in the last 20 or so
years
and and that what you do is you cut your
variable your continuous variable into
into
into into discrete
um sub ranges for example here we've
we've cut
age at 35
and again at at 50
at 65 there's actually a cut at 50 as
well you can't see it here and then the
idea is you fit a constant model in each
of the regions
so it's a piecewise constant model
right so you can see here the
so the function of when when you fit it
and put plot them all together you see
the constant in the first range the
second range the third range is is
hardly visible that it's different and
then the fourth range and so this
becomes when put together as a
non-linear function
it's a piecewise constant function
and this this is often useful if there's
some natural cut points that are of
interest you know so what is the average
income for somebody
below the age of 35 you know so you can
read it straight off the plot
this is often good for for summaries in
newspapers and reports and things like
that which is led to its popularity
and
you know to do it is just as easy
as as as as it was for polynomials
if you if you think of this function
over here it's a
it's a it's a binary variable you make a
binary variable is x less than 35
if yes you make it one if not you make
it a zero
and for each of these it's the same and
so you create a bunch of dummy variables
zero one variables and you just fit
those with a linear model you can always
see the advantage this has over over
polynomials right this is local remember
with polynomials
it's a single function for the whole
range of the of the x variable so for
example if i change a point on the left
side it could potentially change the fit
on the right side quite a bit for
polynomials that's a good point rob
which i forgot to say yeah but for uh
for step functions a fit a point only
affects the the fit in in the partition
it's sitting in and not the other
partitions
that's that's a great point um and and
thanks for for reminding us
the polynomial the parameters affect the
function everywhere
and and can have dramatic effects
here we've done the same thing as we did
before for the logistic regression but
with a piecewise constant function
everything else is the same but the
fitted function is kind of blocky and
you know maybe considered not as
attractive
step functions are easy to work with as
i said you make a bunch of dummy
variables and just fit the linear model
um it's also a useful way of creating
interactions
that are easy to interpret so for
example think of the interaction effect
of year and age in a linear model
so what you can do
is for example make a dummy variable of
of year so let's say cut here less than
or equal to
less than 2005
and and have another one here bigger
than equal to 2005 and then if you
multiply that with age what you've done
is create an interaction and that'll fit
a linear different linear model
as a function of age for the for
people who worked before 2005 and those
after 2005.
and and so that visually that's nice
you'll see two different linear
functions it's the easy way of seeing
the effect of an interaction
and in r
creating these dummy variables is really
easy
creating an indicator function is is a
pretty much the same expression we've
shown up till now
there's a there is a function in r which
is basically an indicator
and here less than 25
turns into a logical but when wrapped in
the indicator it's essentially a zero
one variable
and
if you want to cut in more than one
place there's a function called cut so
you can cut age and you give it the cut
points you need to give cut the two
boundary points as well and so in this
case 18 and 90 those are the ranges of
the ages it will be on the age range
actually and then the interior cut
points and it'll create a factor for you
an ordered factor that cuts the variable
into those bins
now the choice of the cut points or
knots as we're going to call them can be
a little problematic
if we're creating non-linearity smooth
alternatives
are available and we're going to talk
about them next
you might just pick an unfortunate
choice of cut points and it doesn't show
the non linearity at all and so there's
somewhat of an art so usually these
piecewise constant functions are
especially good if they are natural cut
points that you want to use